[Music]
hi
it's michelle from lapland beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd and
cranky old lady
today i'm going to be talking about
products i hate honestly it isn't even
the product most of the time it's just
the marketing around it that i hate
if you like noting out about the science
behind beauty products click the
subscribe and the notification bell so
you don't miss any videos
let's start with coffee scrubs coffee
scrubs are usually a mix of oil and
coffee grounds and coffee grounds are
the things that you have left over after
you've made coffee
so you grind the coffee soak it in water
all the water comes out and becomes your
coffee and then you're left with
gunk and that gunk is what's in your
coffee scrub
so instead of putting it in the garbage
where it belongs they put it in a bag
with preservatives and then sell it back
to you for about 20 bucks
it's basically really expensive diy
skincare the way that most of these
coffee scrub companies convince people
to still buy their product
is pretty much false advertising most of
the time there are all these claims that
they get rid of cellulite stretch marks
and scars
caffeine can reduce the appearance of
cellulite but
not really in the form of coffee scrubs
based on the studies on leave on
caffeine creams and cellulite
you would need to have 2.1 kilograms of
coffee grounds left on your legs for
hours
there's no evidence for caffeine helping
with stretch muscle scars
massage can help but you can massage
with anything so any improvements that
you see with a coffee scalp are probably
a combination of massage exfoliation and
good old placebo
you're seeing what you think you should
be seeing and really this shouldn't cost
that much
there's also the fact that coffee scrubs
are really messy they tend to leave
black bits in your shell because they
don't dissolve and so you have to scrub
yourself and then scrub your shower
which to me is just an
awful lot of scrubbing there's also the
fact that cellulite is a perfectly
normal part of a woman's body
most women have it and there's nothing
wrong with having it it's not like some
sort of pathology so i feel like these
companies sometimes overstep the idea
that you should be scrubbing these away
i think
is quite damaging so instead if you do
want to reduce the appearance of
cellulite i would recommend getting a
proper caffeine cream
if you want exfoliation without the mess
i'd recommend getting a sugar or salt
scrub
you can even mix your own by putting oil
in some sugar or some salt
and that would be a lot more cost
effective the next type of product is
anti-blue light products that are
designed to protect you from screens
if you've seen my videos on visible
light damage and blue light you'll know
why these are bs
blue light can have effects on skin in
in vitro studies on skin cells it's been
found that blue light can cause skin
cells to produce more free radicals
and this could theoretically lead to
faster skin aging but this hasn't been
tested in clinical trials and skin cells
in a petri dish are very different from
skin cells in skin
clinical studies have also found that
darker skin can develop
hyperpigmentation with blue light
but the amount that comes from screens
is really tiny compared to the amounts
used in studies
the only people who need to be concerned
about the tiny amounts of light coming
from screens
are people with photosensitivity
conditions you would know if you have
one of these conditions because your
doctor would have told you to be really
careful about turning on lights inside
your house
you would need to sit in front of your
screen for days or months to get the
same amount of visible light that you'd
get from 15 minutes of sunshine
this sounds kind of scary because we all
know that the sun causes skin damage
it leads to cancer and accelerated skin
aging
but the reason we're scared of the sun
is uv not visible light
visible light from the sun hasn't been
linked to skin cancer or
aging so there's no reason why brands
who are selling anti-blue light products
should be focusing on screens rather
than the sun
but most of them are and so like a lot
of other fear-mongering marketing i
think they're really trying to tap into
and exploit
our bias towards natural things we like
to think that things that are natural
like the sun are okay but things that
are artificial like screens on the
internet
are bad for us in some way even though
especially during this pandemic screens
have been really good
they've been helping a lot of us keep
socially connected and able to earn
income while staying safe but a lot of
brands have been coming out with these
products during lockdown and i think
it's really
just shady and opportunistic a more
likely way that blue light from screens
might be messing with your skin
is by messing up your sleep schedule
there's some evidence that blue light
can suppress melatonin which is a
hormone that makes you sleepy but you
can fix this with a blue light filter
app
a lot of these are free and you wouldn't
fix this with a skin care product
shade rollers and gouache are tools now
facial massage is really nice and
soothing
it can help you relax tight muscles it
can also push out lymphatic fluid and
that can make your face look more toned
it's also good for a cooling effect and
i personally actually quite enjoy using
these massage tools
the problem again is the marketing it
really tends to oversell the benefits
so you have claims like massaging your
face can increase your blood circulation
this lets your skin release toxins and
calms inflammation
it can get rid of wrinkles stimulate
collagen production
reduce cell tone over time minimize
enlarged pores
boost elastin minimize spots caused by
toxin buildup and it can reduce sagging
now theoretically improving your
circulation could possibly lead to
increased collagen production
but this has never been shown it's a bit
like claiming that because fast food
gives you energy and energy makes you
run faster eating lots of fast food
would make you a really good athlete
there's a theoretical mechanism but
without more solid data
you can't make this sort of claim i
think these tools also rely a lot on
exoticism to sell so this is the whole
ancient chinese secret sort of marketing
i don't think it's a coincidence that
jade rollers in particular really took
off and that gouache our tools took off
rather than facial massage stones
there's also a lot of crystal
pseudoscience involved so there's a
brand that claims that rose quartz is an
emotional healer
and that reduces and releases impurities
and stress and skin
really good for detoxing and somehow
this emotional healer also helps you
with
fine lines and wrinkles amethysts are
meant to be good for calming
inflammation and
acne red jasper is a stone of vibrancy
and endurance and therefore it's good
for hyperpigmentation
now i think this crystal stuff is a
relatively harmless pseudoscience but it
still has some harms
medical pseudoscience with healing
claims can lead people to delay
treatment for their medical conditions
and that can mean that it's a lot harder
to treat
there are also serious issues with how
crystals are sourced a lot of them come
from mines where the workers have really
bad conditions
in a lot of these places there's a lack
of regulations which means there's
things like
child labour and people getting serious
injuries while mining these rocks
and of course a lot of these workers
aren't being fairly paid i've put a link
in the description to an article where
you can read more about this
spf drops so spf sunscreen drops are
products that you're meant to mix into
other products to basically turn it into
a sunscreen so you don't have to use a
regular sunscreen
sunscreens don't always have good
textures and they break a lot of people
out like me
and so this is a really appealing
product but like a lot of other really
appealing ideas it
doesn't work sunscreen drops say they
have high spf but this is for the
product on its own not after you've
mixed a few drops into something else
mixing a few drops into your foundation
or moisturizer means you're going to be
diluting it quite a lot
as i've mentioned before if you dilute a
sunscreen it becomes way less effective
protection scales pretty much linearly
so if you dilute it by half you get half
the spf
three drops is about 0.15 mils so that
means on my face it would give me an spf
of somewhere between 5 and 10.
now theoretically you could apply them
like a regular sunscreen and get the
proper amount of protection
but everything about the product
encourages you to only apply a few drops
the fact that it comes in a dropper
bottle
the instructions the fact that it's a
tiny bottle the fact that it's an
expensive bottle
now even if we had a really high
protection product let's say spf 500
drops
it's still not a good idea to mix
products yourself to try to make a
sunscreen
that's because how well a sunscreen
works isn't just about how much active
ingredient you have
it's also about how that active
ingredient is spread out
there are a lot of things that can
impact this so what the other
ingredients in your mixed product are
whether or not they interact with each
other how it spreads over your skin
and how it dries and this is why
sunscreen is one of the hardest products
to formulate so there's a whole bunch of
variables that this mixing doesn't take
into account
there's also the fact that if you're
mixing these drops together you're
probably not mixing them evenly
you also can't predict how these two
products will interact with each other
when you mix them
so if you think about products balling
up or foundation separating
so you're probably getting patchy
protection with this sort of spf mix
where some parts of your skin aren't
getting enough protection but i guess
you're probably only getting about spf 5
so maybe it doesn't even matter you're
probably better off using a foundation
with spf and we all know that that isn't
enough
just use a proper dedicated sunscreen so
maybe i'm being a little bit harsh
because the products themselves aren't
necessarily bad it's just how you're
meant to use them and how they're
marketed which i think are really bad i
don't know are you also really annoyed
about these products leave me a comment
letting me know and if you have other
products that you also hate
click the thumbs up and subscribe it
really helps my videos on the algorithm
you can also follow me on instagram and
you can check out my blog for more
beauty science
see you next time to nerd out more